في يوم 29 يونيو اللي فات وكاله رويترز
قدرت بشكل حصري تكشف عن نتائج كانت بمثابه
قنبله في اوساط الوكالات الحكوميه الصحيه
وشركات الاغذيه والمشروبات في العالم كله
من وقتها والحد اللحظه اللي بصور فيها
تقرير رويترز ببساطه بيقول ان بناء على
النتايج اللي توصلت لها الوكاله الدوليه
لابحاث السرطان المعروفه اختصارا باي ارك
وهي زراعه ابحاث السرطان التابعه لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه فهي بتستعد لاول مره
لادراج ماده من اشهر المحليات الصناعيه في
العالم على انها محتمل تكون مسرطنه
للانسان الماده دي هي الاسبر بتاعها واللي
بيتم استخدامها كبديل للسكر في الاف
المنتجات اللي بيصنعها بعض اكبر مصنعي
المواد الغذائيه في العالم بنلاقيها في
المشروبات الغازيه الخاصه بالحميه
الغذائيه او الدايت والايس كريم وبعض
انواع الزبادي الدايت وبعض انواع العلكه
او اللبان الخالي من السكر كل المنتجات دي
وغيرها كمان المنتجات اللي بنشربها او
بناكلها كل يوم تقريبا زي المنتجات اللي
شفتوها في بدايه الحلقه واكتر وبالفعل
بعدها باسبوعين حصل للي نوهت عنه يوم
الجمعه اللي فاتت 14 يوليو ادرجت منظمه
الصحه العالميه ماده الاسبرتان كمان دم
المواد المحتمله اللي ممكن تسبب السرطان
عند البشر بعد ما عملت اعاده تقييم للمحلل
اكثر استخداما على ظهر الكوكب بناء على
تجارب ابحاث موثوقه وده تسبب في حاله من
الغليان في اوساط صناعات الاغذيه العالميه
فايه ماده الاسبرتام دي وازاي احنا
بنستهلكها بكثافه وليد صنفت كماده مسرطنه
وازاي اصلا الوكالات الصحيه الحكوميه
العالميه سمحت بادخالها كمحل عام في عدد
كبير من الاغذيه والمشروبات من 40 سنه
وايه اهم الاطعمه والمشروبات اللي فيها
الاسبرتام وايه تاثير قرارها على الشركات
اللي بتستخدم الاسبرتام دي عينه من
الاسئله المهمه والخطيره جدا اللي هنجاوب
عليها في حلقه النهارده اللي لازم تشوفها
للاخر وتشاركها مع كل معارفك لان الموضوع
مش بسيط احنا بنتكلم على ماده بقى لنا
سنين طويله بندخلها جوه اجسامنا وفجاه
حيتم ادراجها لاول مره كماده محتمله
مسرطنه فمحتاجين نفهم بالظبط ايه الحكايه
يلا بينا اشرف ابراهيم المخ بالاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
عايز اشكر شركه اكسناس العالميه لرعايتها
الحلقه دي وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في
الاسواق الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز
الاتنين تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل
مع علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انها مرخصه
ومراقبه من هيئات رقبيه التانيه بعرف اسحب
فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري
الثالثه ان عملتهم منخفضه الرابعه ان
التداول بيتنفس بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
والدهب هتلاقوا لينك ليهم تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك انت بدات الحكايه بدات سنه
1965 لما جيمس شلاتر الكيميائي في شركه
الادويه الامريكيه جي دي سريل كان بيحاول
يلاقي دواء يكون مضاد للقرح فمن ضمن
التجارب اللي كان بيجربها العلاج القرحه
انه خلط اثنين من الاحماض الامينيه
الطبيعيه على بعض وهم حمض الاسبرتيك
والفانيل فطلع مركب معين وبالصدفه البحث
عمنا جيمس يبدو انه غامه الص المركب ده
وبعدها لعقه فاكتشف حلاوه المركب ده طعم
وكان مسكر جدا احلى بحوالي 200 مره من
السكر العادي وفي نفس الوقت اتضح انه
منخفض السعرات الحراريه جدا كان اكتشاف
مبهر في الوقت ده ومن هنا بدات محاولات
ادخاله في تصنيع المواد الغذائيه كمحله
بديل للسكر بسبب الاضرار الصحيه الكبيره
للشكر لكن قررت اعتماد الاسبارتان في
الولايات المتحده كمحله صناعي شائع ودخوله
في مجموعه واسعه من الاطعمه والمشروبات
وبعض الادويه زي ادويه السعال من 40 سنه
يعتبر من اكثر القرارات المثيره للجدل
السياسي واللي كان عليها علامات استفهام
كبيره او زي ما بيطلقوا عليها لقب واحده
من الموافقات الاكثر جدلا في تاريخ اداره
الغذاء والدواء بعد اكتشاف الاسمر تم
سنتين تقريبا بدات شركه سيريل اختبارات
السلامه الحتميه علشان تتقدم بطلب للحصول
على موافقه اداره الغذاء والدواء
ثم تبدا تسوقه للشركات المختلفه بحيث يدخل
في منتجعتها على مدار خمس سنين عند فاقد
شركه عشرات الملايين من الدولارات على
اختبارات السلامه ثم جاءت اخيرا في شهر
فبراير سنه 1973
وتقدمت بطلب لاداره الغذاء والدواء وقدمت
اكتر من 100 دراسه بتدعي ان الاسبرتان
ماده امنه ركزوا معايا في الجزئيه اللي
جايه دي يا اخواننا علشان نعرف ازاي
الكارثه دي حصلت من البدايه في سنه 1974
اداره الغذاء والدواء اعلنت موافقتها
الاوليه وبالتالي منح الاذن لشركه سيريل
على استخدام الاسبرتاع ولكن قبل ما يتم
اعتماد القرار كان في علماء مستقلين
بيجروا ابحاث ودراسات على الاسبرتام
واعترضوا وقالوا ان الماده ممكن تسبب
التخلف العقلي واضرار في المخ واضطرابات
في الغدد الصماء العصبيه في فريق ثاني من
العلماء اعترضوا برده وقالوا ان شركه
سيريل في اجراء اختبارات السلامه الخاصه
بشكل صحيح وان التجارب المختبريه بتاعتهم
كانت غير مطابقه للمواصفات ومليانه
بخطواته نتايج غير دقيقه وان بيانات
الاختبار تم التلاعب بها وفريق تالت من
علماء قسم الادويه جوه اداره الغذاء
والدواء نفسها لما اطلعوا على الدراسات
والسجلات المختبريه اللي عملتها شركه
سيريل اكتشفوا ان نسبه كبيره من العمل
التجريبي اللي عملته الشركه كان غير موثوق
فيه لحد كبير الطبيعي والمنطقي بعد كل ده
ان اداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه ترفض
طلب شركه سيريل بتسويق الاسبرتان وادخاله
في الاطعمه والمشروبات ولكن اللي حصل بعد
كده كان مثير للغيبه وغريب جدا اداره
الغذاء والدواء طلعت قالت انها غير قادره
على اجراء جميع المراجعات بسبب نقص
الموارد بتاعتها وبالتالي الزمت شركه
سيريل بالتعاقد مع منظمه اسمها اتحاد
الجامعات الامريكيه للبحث والتوعيه في علم
الامراض
اختصارا
طبعا قرار اداره الغذاء والدواء
بالاستعانه بجهه خارجيه وبالذات الجهه دي
كان قرار محير جدا لسببين اولا ان اداره
الغذاء والدواء يدوب كانوا لسه واخدين
تمويل جديد من الكونجس الامريكي في شهر
ابريل سنه 1976 علشان يقدروا بشكل كامل
يفحصوا بيانات التسمم في الصناعات
الكيميائيه فتمش معهم موارد والسبب التاني
ان الجهه دي تحديدا ما كانش عندها الخبره
المطلوبه للحكم على نتائج التجارب الاجريت
على الحيوانات الحيه وبالتالي هيتم
الاعتماد على تقييمها اخيرا في سنه 1978
اصدرت المنظمه دي تقريرها المكون من 1062
صفحه ولا خالص لان الدراسات اللي هم
عملوها تدقيق كانت موثوقه يعني باختصار
الاسبارتين ماده طبعا بعدها تم تقديم
اعتراضات ضخمه على سلامه الاسبرتا فاداره
الغذاء بقى علشان تحل الخلاف ده قررت
انشاء ما يسمى بالبابلك بورد اوبن او مجلس
التحقيق العام والمعروفه اختصارا
ودي بالمناسبه المره الوحيده اللي تم
تشكيل المجلس ده فيها وهو عباره عن لجنه
مكونه من ثلاث علماء اكاديميين مستقلين عن
اداره الغذاء والدواء وعن شركه المهم
الناس المحترمه دول بداوا شغلهم في اوائل
سنه 1980 وعلى شهر اكتوبر من نفس السنه
كانوا طالعين باستنتاجاتهم وكانت كالتالي
استهلاك الاسبرتام لن يشكل خطر متزايد على
الدماغ يسبب تخلف عقلي ولكن الادله
المتاحه لا تستبعد احتمال ان يتسبب
الاسبرتاند في اورام في الدماغ وبناء عليه
المجلس اوصى بعدم السماح باستخدام
الاسبرتان في انتظار نتائج المزيد من
الاختبارات طبعا بعدها اعترضت شركه سيرل
على الاستنتاجات دي ولان المجلس كان دروس
استشاري بس مش ملزم لاداره الغذاء
الامريكيه ففي شهر يوليو سنه 1981 قرر
مفوض الاداره ارثر جونيور يرمي كل دوره
ضهره واعلن قراره بالموافقه على استخدام
الاسبرتام في منتجات غذائيه غير المشروبات
الغازيه طبعا حضراتكم مستغربين دلوقتي
ازاي ده يحصل في دوله ديمقراطيه وفيها قدر
من الشفافيه زي الولايات المتحده وليه
اصلا ايه السبب في تفصيله بسيطه هتفسر لنا
كل اللي فات ده سنه 1977 مين اللي اصبح
الرئيس التنفيذي الجديد لشركه سيرل هو
الراجل اللي جنبي على الشاشه ده اكيد
معظمكم هيعرفوا من ايام غزو الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها للعراق سنه 2003 وكان هو
العقل المدبر للحرب دي واول حد الدعم
العراق بيمتلك برنامج نشط لانتاج اسلحه
دمار شامل كتبرير وتمهيد للغزو دونالد
ترامس فيلد ترامب قبل ما يتعين كرئيس
تنفيذ لشركه سيريل سنه 1977 كان احد ابرز
شخصيات العاصمه واشنطن عضو سابق في
الكونجرس ومسك قبلها مباشره وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه في عهد الرئيس الامريكي جرى
الفورد طبعا رمز فيلد لما تعين رئيس
للشركه جاب معاه شخصيات مهمه في واشنطن
وعينهم في الاداره العليا للشركه وفي
يناير سنه 1981 الرئيس الامريكي رونالد
ريجن ادى اليمين كرئيس للولايات المتحده
ضمن الفريق الانتقالي بتاعه
ركزوا معايا يا اخوانا بعد مادونالد ريجن
حلف اليمين مباشره اما عين مفوض جديد
لاداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه اللي هو
مين بقى بالظبط ارثر جونيور اللي وافق على
استخدام الاسبارتان اللي بتصنعوا شركه بعد
شهور قليله بس من تعيينه من وقتها دخل
الاسبرتام السوق كمحله منخفض السعرات
واصبح مكون رئيسي في الاطعمه والمشروبات
في الولايات المتحده وبعدها وافقت الوكاله
الاوروبيه لسلامه الغذاء المعروفه اختصارا
بافسا على استخدامه اوروبا ثم بدا ينتشر
في جميع انحاء العالم لحد ما وصلنا هنا في
الوطن العربي من التسعينات بقى بدا
العلماء يركزوا اكتر على مدى سلامه
الاسبرتام في ابحاثهم ودراساتهم كمكون
اصبح منتشر في الاف المنتجات الغذائيه
والمشروبات وتقريبا اغلب الدراسات اللي
اتعملت من علماء مستقلين او جهات علميه
معينه ملهاش مصلحه واشاره الى ان
الاسبرتام ممكن يلعب دور في اصابتنا
بالسرطان كان بيتم مهاجمتها والتشكيك في
دقتها من جهاته علماء تانيين ممولين من
اطراف ليهم مصلحه في استمرار الماده دي في
السوق وفي السياق ده هنبص على دراستين بس
من اكبر الدراسات اللي اتعملت على الاسبرت
حديثا هنلاقي نتائج دراسه كبيره تم
الاعلان عنها السنه اللي فاتت 2022 في
جامعه الشربوه وباريس في فرنسا شارك فيها
100 الف شخص بالغ ووصلت فتره المتابعه
فيها لتسع سنين دراسه رصد ضخمه تاثير
استهلاك الاشخاص للمحليات الصناعيه بكميات
كبيره نتائج الدراسه اظهرت ان الاشخاص
اللي بيستهلكوا المحليات الصناعيه بما
فيها الاسبورتام معرضين لخطر الاصابه
بالسرطان بدرجه اكبر من غيرهم الدراسه
اظهرت برضو ان استهلاك المحليات مرتبط
بزياده خطر الاصابه بحالات مرضيه بتؤثر
على تدفق الدم للدماغ بنسبه 20% تقريبا
بالاضافه لامراض القلب زي النوبات القلبيه
والسكتات الدماغيه الكبيره والصغيره
والسباحات الصدريه والعلماء اثبتوا في
الدراسه دي برضو ان استهلاك المحليات
الصناعيه ارتبط بسياده خطر الاصابه بامراض
القلب نسبه 9%
وارتبطان تحديدا بزياده خطر الاصابه
بالامراض الدماغيه الوعائيه بنسبه 17% وفي
دراسه تانيه لا تقل شهره اعملها معهد
رمزيني وهو مختبر ابحاث مستقل وغير هدف
للربح في ايطاليا المختبر ده بدا يجري من
سنين سلسله من الدراسات السميه واسعه
النطاق على الفئران لتحديد اذا كان في
علاقه بين الاسبرتام والسرطان الدراسات
اتعملت على 3122 فار تعرضوا لجرعات مختلفه
من الاسبرتام على مدار عمرهم العلماء
الايطاليين اكتشفوا ان الاسبرتام تسبب في
زياده حدوث الاورام الخبيثه في اعضاء
متعدده داخل الفراخ فلاحظوا زيادات في
اورام الانسجه المكونه للدم والانسجه
اللمفاويه في الجنسيه وسرطان الحوض الكلوي
والحالب في الاناث وسرطان الثدي في الاناث
واورام الاعصاب الطرفيه في الذكور طبعا
بعد نشر نتائج الدراستين دول وغيرهم حصلت
حاله من الجدل الحاد في الاوساط العلميه
والوكالات الصحيه الحكوميه اللي سمحت
بالاسبرتام زي الوكاله الاوروبيه لسلامه
الاغذيه لما طلعت تشكك في الدراسات دي
علماء تانيين عرضه النتايج خاصه نتائج
دراسه مختبر رمزيني ولكن اللي تم ملاحظته
ان جزء كبير العلماء دول كان بيتم تمويلهم
من قبل اطراف الصناعه اللي بتستفيد من
استهلاك الاسبر بتاعها زي جمعيه المشروبات
الامريكيه وشركه اللي بتورد الاسبرتان في
مجلس مراقبه السعرات الحراريه الكيانات دي
بتمثل لوبيات او جامعات ضغط بتحافظ على
مصالح الشركات اللي شغاله في الصناعه دي
يعني مثلا جمعيه المشروبات الامريكيه دي
عباره عن مجموعه ضغط حكوميه امريكيه بتمثل
صناعه المشروبات الامريكيه والاعضاء
بتوعها عباره عن منتجي معبئي المشروبات
الغازيه زي كوكاكولا وبيبسي وكاله
بالاضافه لاعضاء من شركات بتصنع المشروبات
غير الكحليه التانيه الصناعه المرتبطه
بالاسبارتان صناعه ضخمه بمليارات
الدولارات يا اخواننا وبالتالي الطبيعي
نلاقي الدفاع المستميل ده عن مصالح
الشركات المستفيده منها خاصه وان
الاسبرتام احد اكثر المحليات الصناعيه
استخداما في العالم وبيتم انتاج من 3000 ل
5000 طن متري من الاسبرتام سنويا
وفي بعض انواع الايس كريم والصلصات
والسناكس وقطرات السعال وحبوب الافطار في
اسماء تجاريه تانيه الاسبرتام لما يكون
موجود على الطاوله ويتم استخدامه كبديل
للسكر في المشروبات الساخنه زي الشاي مثلا
او القهوه من اسماء التجاريه دي نيوترا
سويد وايكوال
طيب لو انا متعود اشتري منتج معين خالي من
السكر او متعلق بالضيق ومش عارف
الاسبارتام موجود فيه ولا لا اعمل ايه
ببساطه ببص على المكونات بتاعته فلو هو في
الاسبرتين في حنلاقي الكلمه مكتوبه
بالعربي او بالانجلش او حنلاقي الرمز
بتاعه اللي هو اي 1951 او اي ان اس 951 او
سويتر 951 هنا بقى يجي سؤال مهم خطير
تقريبا كلنا اكلنا وشربنا حاجات فيها
سبورت فايه وضع الناس اللي اكلت وشربت
منتجات فيها سبارتام على مدار سنين هل لا
قدر الله كده بقوا مصابين بالسرطان غالبا
لا فحضراتكم لانه في حدود امنه لاستهلاك
الاسبرت تقريبا جميع الجهات التنظيميه
متفقه على حدود الاستهلاك الامن للماده في
اليوم واداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه
وضحت ان الحد المقبول لاستهلاك الاسبورتام
هو خمسين مللي جرام لكل كيلو جرام من وزن
الجسم يوميا والهيئه الاوروبيه لسلامه
الاغذيه حددته باقل من كده وقالت انه
المفروض الاستهلاك اليومي للاسبارتام ما
يزيدش عن اربعين مللي جرام لكل كيلو جرام
من وزن الجسم وده معناه انه لو شخص بالغ
وزنه 70 كيلو مثلا فالمفروض ما يستهلكش
اكتر من 2800 مللي جرام من الاسبرتام في
اليوم يوم الجمعه اللي فاتت منظمه الصحه
العالميه من خلال الوكاله الدوليه الابحاث
السرطان قالت ان في صله محتمله بين
الاسبرتام ونوع من سرطان الكبد يسمى سرطان
الخلايا الكبديه واستندت في قرارها على
مراجعه ثلاث دراسات كبيره اتعملت على
البشر في الولايات المتحده واوروبا
الوكاله الدوليه حصى السرطان دي بتستخدم
اربع تصنيفات للعناصر المثيره للقلق اول
مشكوك في خطورتها وتسببها للسرطان
المجموعه واحد كارث او ماده مسرطنه
للانسان والمجموعه دي معناها ان في دليل
كافي على تسبب ما في المجموعه دي باصابه
البشر بالسرطان زي الكحول والاشعاع المعين
المجموعه اتنين
او ماده قد تصيب البشر بالسرطان بنسبه 50%
او اكتر والمجموعه دي معناها ان في ادله
محدوده على تسبب عناصرها باصابه البشر
بالسرطان ولكن في ادله كافيه من خلال
التجارب اللي تمت على بعض الحيوانات
المجموعه دي بتضم عناصر زي اللحوم الحمراء
متلوث الهواء الخارجي المجموعه الثالثه
او ماده قد تصيب البشر بالسرطان بنسبه 50%
او اقل والمجموعه دي معناها ان في ادله
محدوده على تسبب عناصرها باصابه البشر
بالسرطان وادله غير كافيه برضو من خلال
التجارب على الحيوانات ودي المجموعه اللي
انضم اليها الاسبرت وفيها عناصر تانيه زي
المجالات المغناطيسيه للترددات الراديويه
اللي بتطلع من العديد من الاجهزه
الالكترونيه الشائعه زي الهواتف المحموله
وفيها كرات النفسانيين اللي بتستخدم
لحمايه الملابس من العفه وفيها برضو
الخضروات المخلله الاسيويه المجموعه
الرابعه نطق لصفا اولا يمكن تصنيفها
والمجموعه دي معناها انه مفيش ادله كافيه
حتى الان على تسبب عناصرها في اصابه البشر
او حيوانات التجارب بالسرطان وبتدوم عناصر
زي بعض انواع التخدير وزراعه الثدي
بالسيليكون مصبغات الشعر طبعا اللي عمل كل
الضجه دي انه تم تصنيف الاسبرتام في
المجموعه الثالثه لاول مره وده ما كانش
موجود قبل كده ممكن شركات الاغذيه
والمشروبات تطنش وتستمر في استخدام
الاسبرتان في منتجاتها عادي ولكن ده هيكون
له عواقب مش لطيفه لان الشركات دي هتكون
في مرمى نيران المحاكم بعد كده لو اترفع
الدعوه ان حد اصيب بالسرطان بسبب الاسبارت
عام وهتكون في وقتها تعويضات بالملايين
والدولارات زي ما حصل مع منتجاته شركات
تانيه يعني مثلا في 2015 الوكاله الدوليه
لابحاث السرطان صنفت الجليفسات الموجود في
مبيدات الحشائش على انه ماده مسرطنه
محتمله ضمن المجموعه التانيه طبعا كائنات
كتيره طعنت في التصنيف ده زي الهيئه
العامه الامريكيه لرقابه الماليه وطبعا
جنبها شركه بايرن لانها بتصنع مبيد
الاعشاب المعروف بتاعها راوند اب معتمد
على شركه دي خسرت جميع الدعاوى القضائيه
اللي رفعها شخصيا من ولايه كاليفورنيا
اتهموا الشركه ان مبيد الاعشاب بتاعها سبب
لهم نوع من انواع سرطانات الغدد اللمفاويه
واتحاكم على الشركه في النهايه سنه 2021 ب
25 مليون دولار تعويضات من وقتها والشركه
بتحاول تحتوي القضايا لمرفوعه عليها لدرجه
انها التزمت بدفع 9.6 مليار دولار لتسويه
125,000 مط متعلقه بمنتجها وعلى فكره
اثناء التقاضي الشركه كانت بتقول برضو زي
لوبيات صناعه الاغذيه والمشروبات ان في
عقود من الدراسات ازهرت ان من بدايه
الاعشاب القائمه على الجليفوسات امنه
للاستخدام البشري وان الجلايفوسات تمت
الموافقه عليه من قبل وكاله حمايه البيئه
كماده امنه للبشر نصيحتي انا الشخصيه
نحاول نقلل بقدر الامكان من المنتجات اللي
فيها الاسبرتان ولو قدرنا نبعد عنها خالص
يبقى افضل الشركات العملاقه اللي بتضخ
مليارات الدولارات للتاثير على الابحاث او
للتشكيك في ابحاث تانيه مع الاله
الاعلاميه الجباره بتاعتهم مسببه حاله من
الضبابيه في المشهد وغلوشه مش من مصلحتها
ان المستهلكين يعرفوا الحقايق كامله محدش
هينفعك غير نفسك حافظ عليها وخلي عندك
اكبر قدر من الالتزام ناحيه صحتك ده غير
انه بعيدا عن اي شيء في معظم المنتجات
اللي داخل فيها الاسبارتام مضره بعيدا عن
الماده نفسها فالافضل نبطلها لحد هنا انا
خلصت كلامي وكالعاده عندي سؤال لحضراتكم
ايه اكتر منتجات بتستهلكوها من اللي
ذكرناها في الحلقه وهل هتبطلوها ولا
هتكملوا استهلاك المنتجات دي عادي هتابع
اجاباتكم كلها في التعليقات اللي عايز
يشتري اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا شركه
اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ما تنسوش
تشتركوا في القناه ويا ريت لو عجبتكم
الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو واهم
حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن
يستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]